-Welcome back, welcome back.
"Batwoman."
-Yeah.
-It's official.
-Oh, it's very official.
It comes out -- Last time,
we were announcing it,
and now it's airing.
But I feel like I saw you
like a week ago.
-I want to hear about this.
I want to know --
what did it feel like
the first time
you put on the suit?
Talk to me.
-The suit felt amazing.
Colleen Atwood designed it.
She is an Oscar winner.
It's like a second skin
and it feels like
you're faster and stronger
and better and bulletproof,
but you're none of those things.
You're a little slower.
And it's a little uncomfortable
on the back after a while.
-But, I mean, I see there's ads
all over the place right now.
They're doing a great job
marketing this thing.
But you look so cool.
-It's everywhere.
-You look great.
-Like, I've been living in
a bubble that is a Batcave
that is -- It's in Vancouver.
which is the city
I don't even live in,
like, until now.
And then I come here and I,
like, had a panic attack
because I was like,
"Oh, my God, this is amazing.
I'm there and I'm there."
And then a bus, like,
of myself swiped to my face,
and I was like, "Whoa!
Well, that would have been
really ironic."
And then there was, like --
And then I saw it on, like,
a little subway thing
and I was like,
"I need to get back
to my hotel.
This is just --"
It really freaked me out.
-This is the first time --
No one has ever played
Batwoman before.
-No one has ever played her,
except me now.
And it comes out next week,
and I'm terrified.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I'm so happy for you.
-I'm happy. I'm thrilled.
-And can we talk about something
that had happened on set?
You had an injury.
-I did.
-Explain this.
This is, like --
-Well, I had a couple of,
like, comedies of error
when you're really hyped
about a show.
One was that I was allergic
to my cowl, my mask.
And, so, I'm, like,
allergic to the adhesive tape,
so I had, like, hives for,
like, a little while.
-You're joking.
-No.
About five days, six days in,
it was like,
we took -- On, like,
the morning I was like
a pre-Proactiv
15-year-old-child
kind of commercial.
-Yeah.
-And then, when I took it off,
I was, like, in a horror film,
like, where people were like,
"It's going to be okay.
Can you just stay back there?
Just stay there."
-"Who are you?"
-"We're going to call someone.
Just don't take a step.
No, don't come near me.
Don't."
-So, what did they have to do?
Change the whole make --
-Yeah, we had to take everything
out of it and put, like,
something else --
cotton or something -- in it.
And then -- But before that, I
broke my neck, basically,
on the show, as well.
-Talk to me about this,
'cause this is --
You can't even just say
that flippantly.
It's awful.
-Well, that one -- You know,
that's, like, more funny.
No, it's not at all.
So, I did a stunt,
and for, like,
a very extended amount of
time -- like seven hours --
and we thought that I had broke
a rib or just, like,
fractured a rib,
and that was like
6 to 12 weeks of, like, healing.
So, then I had 6 to 12 weeks
of chronic pain
and just sort of kept assuming
that that what it was,
until I kept seeing
these doctors, and they're like,
"It's your neck,
it's your neck."
It just, like,
radiates into these places
because of nerve endings."
So I finally got an MRI.
And I had to get it in Romania,
in the middle of a film,
where I was also doing stunts.
And I had to send it
to my doctor,
who had to sort of transcribe
the whole thing.
And, basically,
he called and he was like,
"You could become paraplegic.
This is your spine.
Two of your disks
have herniated,
and they've broken all
the protective layers.
You have, like, this tiny amount
that your spine is, like,
not severed,
and if you don't get back,
you could become paraplegic."
Even just, like, sleeping wrong
or, you know,
moving my head
in a strange direction.
-Ruby, this is awful.
-It was so -- It was really,
really terrifying.
And then, you know, I was like,
"Well, at least
I don't have an option."
You know what I mean?
It's like, "I have to do it."
-Yeah.
-So I did the surgery.
And it was --
And, also, I couldn't feel
my arms for a long time,
but you just get used to
weird things like that.
And, so, it was only when
I would, like,
pick things up
and then I would drop them,
and then I was like,
"Well, that's strange."
And then I really didn't --
I wasn't paying attention
to my body.
I wasn't listening.
I was, like, in such a hurry to
get everything done.
It was like, "'Batwoman.'
Yeah, I just did the pilot.
And now I'm going to do
this film.
I'm going to come back, we're
going to pick up the series."
But I just wasn't listening,
and I think that was
the world's way of saying like,
"You're going to have to
pay attention and you're gonna
have to slow down
and you're not actually
a superhero
and you need to get
some priorities straight."
-Wow.
-And I went back to work after
10 days, because, like I said,
my priorities were straight
and I liked to rest.
-Did you freak out?
Did you just go,
"Well, what's --" I mean...
-Well, I didn't have time
to freak out.
I was just like, "This happens
to like a lot of people."
I mean, it got me thinking about
a lot of things,
Just like, for instance,
how do people pay
for the surgery if they need it?
What happens if someone has
the same diagnosis as me,
but they don't have insurance
and they can't get the surgery?
It's not a cheap surgery.
And they have to just,
like, live
not knowing if they could
become paraplegic?
It just --
It was kind of terrifying.
And then my insurance
didn't cover it,
and I was like, "Wait a minute.
This is America."
And, so -- But at least I have
the funds to pay it.
You know what I mean?
It's just, like -- It got me
thinking about so many things.
And then --
-You appreciate everything,
right?
-I appreciate everything.
And then I was really depressed,
because I wasn't allowed
to move for 10 days,
except to use the restroom.
And I got so depressed there
just thinking about, like,
not being able to move
and how, you know,
and not being able to do
things myself.
And it got depressing, and then
the only way
I really got myself out of it
was being, like,
how much exciting things are
happening this year
and also how much, like,
By slowing things down
and being appreciative
and being in the present moment
and appreciating
the people around you
can make you feel like
a million dollars.
-Well, we love you, and I'm so
happy that you're okay.
-Thank you.
-Be careful.
I want you to come back
more and more.
We love you.